I can confirm we have offices working
around the clock and we have now
arrested a fourth person a 48 year old
man from Northern Ireland was arrested
at Stansted Airport earlier today on
suspicion of conspiracy to traffic
people an on suspicion of manslaughter
it follows the arrest of a 38 year old
man and a 38 year old woman from
Warrington during warrants executed in
Cheshire overnight they are currently in
custody
also on suspicion of conspiracy to
traffic people and on suspicion of
manslaughter a 25 year old man arrested
on Wednesday on suspicion of murder
remains in custody
we have begun the process of
transporting the victims from the port
of tilbury to the mortuary at Brimfield
hospital formal identification processes
will take place as well as examinations
to establish the causes of their deaths
I would like to speak directly to anyone
who thinks their loved ones may have
been in the trailer I know you may be
worried about speaking to the police and
I would like to reassure you that we
just want to be able to give the victims
families answers about what has happened
I can't begin to comprehend what some of
you must be going through right now you
have my assurance that Essex Police will
be working tirelessly to understand the
whole picture to this absolute tragedy
I'd also like to make an appeal to
anyone living illegally in this country
who could help our investigation please
come forward and speak to us without
fear I can assure you that your
information will be received in the
strictest confidence and no criminal
action will be taken against you
you